Hollywood loves its sequels we're
constantly bombarded with trailers
posters and concept art for franchise
films but there are quite a few Park
twos and the works that have
successfully stayed relatively under the
radar from biblical epics to 90s
nostalgia fests let's take a look at
some of the sequels you didn't know
we're being made edge of tomorrow - the
groundhog day of alien invasion movies
2014's edge of tomorrow is one of the
best sci-fi films in recent memory
starring Tom Cruise and Emily Blunt this
doug liman flick focuses on a cowardly
major who finds himself reliving the
same day over and over unfortunately
that day involves an army of
extraterrestrials dead set on conquering
earth while the film earned rave reviews
it was a major financial disappointment
so it didn't seem like the edge of
tomorrow story would live to see another
day
but according to original screenwriter
Christopher McQuarrie crews started
pitching a sequel while filming Mission
Impossible rogue nation soon the
screenplay took shape and blunt and
Lyman were on board for part two
sadly Bill Paxton was also set to return
as the mustachioed Master Sergeant but
the beloved actor passed away in
February 2017 Lyman says the film will
be a sequel that's a prequel that is
going to revolutionize how people make
sequels whatever that all means it
sounds like it won't just be deja vu all
over again
the resurrection with the success of
hacksaw Ridge Mel Gibson is enjoying
something of a comeback and his next big
project is a throwback to his most
successful film 2004 is the passion of
the christ passion focused on the last
hours of Jesus Christ's life as the
endured torture after torture before his
death on a cross
despite the unusually gory take on the
well-known tale passion became the
highest-grossing r-rated film in US
history in August 2016 Gibson announced
he was working on a sequel a huge
undertaking called the resurrection with
Braveheart scribe Randall Wallace
writing the screenplay in November
Gibson went on The Late Show with
Stephen Colbert and took a few questions
about the follow-up that he says is
likely still three years out no bad guys
while they're on yeah they're in another
realm Oh
as Colbert notes the bible does suggest
Jesus spent three days in hell so it
sounds like Gibson might have the
Messiah tangling with some literal
demons 2020 can't get here fast enough
the equalizer - in 40 years of acting on
the silver screen Denzel Washington has
never starred in a sequel but that's all
about to change
as Washington is set to revive Robert
McCall the literature loving hitman from
2014's the equalizer officially
announced in April 2015 the equalizer -
is getting the band back together
washington director antoine fuqua and
screenwriter richard wanker all back in
action so why is washington finally
agreeing to a sequel producer Todd black
says the Jason Bourne series inspired
Denzel to finally take the franchise
plunge and he's not the only one on the
project taking big risks black says
Fuqua has a new effect plan which we
can't talk about but it's so freakin
cool you won't believe it not even a
hint dr. evil guess we'll have to wait
but it sounds freakin amazing look for
the equalizer - in 2018 the girl in the
spider's web David Fincher's 2011
adaptation of the Stieg Larsson novel
The Girl with the Dragon Tattoo didn't
earn enough to impress studio executives
so the next book in the series the girl
who played with fire never made it to
the screen in the US however in November
2015 it was announced that everybody's
favorite hacker Lisbeth Salander would
finally return only this time Hollywood
would adapt the girl in the spider's web
the latest novel in the Millennium
series written by David Locker Krantz
after Larson's untimely death a year
later it was revealed that spider's web
will be helmed by fede alvarez the
director behind don't breathe and the
2013 Evil Dead reboots the studio also
plans on recasting the lead role and
rumor has it the producers are
considering Natalie Portman and Scarlett
Johansson among others spider's web is
scheduled to hit theaters in October
2018 the rocketeers
released in 1991 between Robin Hood
Prince of Thieves
and Terminator 2 Judgment Day the two
highest-grossing movies of the year The
Rocketeer crashed and burned at the box
office but over the years this world war
2 era adventure has picked up something
of a cult following inspiring the studio
to finally revisit The Rocketeer
universe in July 2016
Disney finally announced the rocketeers
a follow up taking place about six years
after the events of the original film
our new Rocketeer yet to be cast is an
african-american female pilot who finds
herself in the middle of some serious
Cold War intrigue with an evil rocket
scientist trying to get his hands on the
all-powerful jetpack interestingly the
film is being co-produced by NBA star
Blake Griffin who must have a thing for
rocket packs considering he sported one
in that game fly spot hopefully he'll
have a cameo thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
other cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]